Donald Trump is in court facing 37
charges of mishandling classified
documents and line to investigators and
all the Democrats are rubbing their
hands together thinking they've got him
apart from Joe Biden who's forgotten
what hands are come on man all you're
doing is making Trump even more insane
vendettas to Trump is Like Cocaine to
Scarface Trump is currently in his
office now figuring off vendettas it's
only a matter of time before he comes
out with his machine gun and starts
blasting away say hello to my little
friend it's not little it's enormous
these are my words this is what people
have been saying about me I have the
biggest machine gun the greatest in
America Trump is going to jail but
knowing him he'll become the first
inmate to become president of the United
States of America he'll be inaugurated
in a jumpsuit